he's one of the co-hosts of good morning
football but yet there's three of you
poor of you yeah so how can you be a co
I'm a quad host yeah yeah that's we say
in 2019-20 quad host yeah so uh Kyle
it's good to see you I'm thrilled to be
here this is some list of guests you
guys have today yeah Kevin Hart was a
lot of fun Mike Schuh chef ski was great
so don't screw it up yeah no pressure on
you the greatest guest you could
possibly get Kevin Hart Coach K Olivia
beauty and then I make Peter striker
giggle on TV that's what I do
glad to be here this is fun Kyle is one
of the hosts for the NFL Network's good
morning football which airs Monday
through Friday at 7:00 a.m. Eastern this
is one of the great days of your life
I'm guessing I'm very are you well I
just watched mystic pizza in the green
room it's a tearjerker rights story
about a fishing town of a couple of gals
and a pizza shop very emotional yeah but
Julia Roberts spectacular respect I mean
it might even be peak Roberts people
want to point to the pretty woman but I
go predate mystic pizza
I think it's peak Roberts I do but you
were in soap operas yeah were you ever
you ever work with somebody that was
that beautiful yeah that's what we do
beautiful talk about the men the women
the stagehands and soap operas are like
nines it's incredible yeah I worked my
father on the show victor Cariocas was
played by John Aniston who's the
real-life father of Jennifer Aniston so
I always felt like we were like brother
and sister-in-law in some way it never
worked out that way never met it up you
never met her never once and this was
during pit era Aniston so I had this
whole plan that I'm gonna befriend
myself with John Aniston he's gonna
invite me over to Thanksgiving and I'll
sit next to Pitt and Anna Stan will I'm
gonna be a power cup never have never
even I don't even think I'd like to me I
forgot my lines one time and John
answers like that Scott the offset
terrible soap operas are tough man no
they're not yes they are lot of
memorizing of lines lot can you do that
Dan like Europe your television radio
are you good at memorizing yeah I've
seen people die right there on set
because they can't remember their line
about the love triangle and the amnesia
it's difficult it's six pages
don't miss the two up or you'll screw up
the whole storyline that's taken six
months I've done that okay what was the
strangest storyline of the soap opera
how many days were how many years three
and a half years three nap yours
on days of our last days of our lives
just got renewed fourth 55th season and
BC at one point I found myself lying in
a hospital bed my character Philip and I
was sitting next to Heather Mills
McCartney who's Paul McCartney's wife at
the time Heather Mills McCartney is an
amputee my character had just become an
amputee and we've commiserated about
what it's like to lose a limb as I sat
there in a hospital but now I lost a
limb mind you because I went overseas
and there was a land mines and then I
came back and Dan I'm not making this up
you can google it after my character
went through his came to terms with
losing the limb he became a NASCAR
driver I'm not kidding Philip Carey I
came in Nazca with one leg which I don't
even know if that's possible with what
with the clutch and when I
I respect the storyline I think it's
motivational and I played the hell out
of it but no Daytime Emmy and not making
that up real story but you did actually
lose a leg for the role which I thought
you got to commit that's called
committee yes this is actually a
prosthesis right here it's very cool
it's a lifelike at this point I'm like a
Richard Kimble is chasing that's all I
got but I committed but okay at some
point you go I'm not gonna act yeah I'm
gonna go into sports yeah everybody
leaves the soap opera at one point
because they're gonna be Matt Damon or
they're gonna be Denzel and so was I
three and a half years I say I'm out of
here I'm gonna get my pilot then I'm
gonna do movies and then a couple months
later I was broke and begging to be on
an infomercial I was on one I was an
infomercial with Jose Canseco once a
real real story about selling things the
people at home that was the low points
that I got to get out of acting I really
was and thank God then I got back into
sports which is like running into my old
girlfriend okay but you you decide
you're going to be the producer for Jim
Rome well he decided but I agreed well
you decided you were gonna go for that
job one morning I woke up about noon I
slept in my robe I was an unemployed
actor I grabbed my blackberry curve out
of nowhere there's an email from Jim
Rome who says I've seen this blog that
you keep Ross Tucker my college teammate
who hosts the show a friend of yours so
college teammate when my best friend's
was approached to produce Rome he said
I've said I've seen your writing would
you like to come and work on my show
said I don't know it's not for me but
there's a guy out there in California
his backgrounds a little weird but you
might like him
Rome brought me in we hit it off and I
became his producer
and then didn't you decided you wanted
to be on the air yeah after about I
think six or seven years of like being
behind the glass as we said then I
started feeling in his guest host and it
took six or seven years and that would
do that for a couple of years and then
um then this stuff started happening I
started doing spots on like fs1 and
things and then I got an agent and then
then FL network called was crazy I'm
here no interest in acting again no I
was really bad at it you know I take to
get back I wasn't right as an actor you
know what's really hard is the
auditioning really really hard going in
there and you see there's some
godforsaken hellhole in the valley and
there's a camera tripod set up but it's
not even the casting what's the biggest
movie you audition for all the big ones
I auditioned to be Anakin Skywalker
Captain Kirk
Superman I mean they'd see a 30,000
people in the city to play those roles
but I did all of them I I'm doing scenes
with Lois Lane I walk in you have stupid
you feel walking in Dan you try to take
yourself seriously as an actor and you
walk in and Captain Kirk here mr. Chekov
set the phasers to this and I don't even
know any of that starch I don't speak
Star Trek these guys look like they do
you guys speak Star Trek
McLovin does alright so I auditioned to
be Captain Kirk in the role that went
thank you yes prosper right the one that
went to crisp Chris Pine yeah he came I
auditioned for that and I did my that as
much as I could do with a hoorah
and I thought we had everything but they
didn't see you feel the same way I never
got the role the last one the straw that
broke the camel's back is I edition they
were rebooting Knight Rider the old
Hasselhoff show and they were bringing
it back and it came back for about five
seconds but I did the scene I was gonna
be the new Michael Knight and the scene
in the audition was with the Hasselhoff
comes back and you're standing over his
grave and he comes up behind you and
he's alive and I think I can get this
got called back like three times I
thought there's gonna be the one didn't
get it didn't get it wasn't even close I
don't think I think I just like twelve
more guys cuz I could see a little
Hasselhoff in you that's compliment yeah
yeah right yeah Knight Rider Baywatch
the guy drunk on the floor eating the
cheeseburger I couldn't do that right
remember that cheeseburger video that
was nuts he was shirtless and everything
like he got a hassle if anything that I
could be that one for the number one
story on Good Morning football is what
I think I think it's right now it's
Eagle Saints that Eagle Saints game this
weekend because we're all caught in this
prism in between what is real and what
we see which is the Saints this answer
at home they've way too many good
players versus what we all want to
believe in something we want to believe
in Nick Falls we want to believe I mean
it sounds good it's almost like we want
to believe in magic we have a shrine set
up on good morning football which we
offer sacrificial mementos to Nick Foles
and last the last thing we offered to
the shrine last week was was oven mitts
from Freddie Mitchell and sure enough
then they win because someone gets their
mitts on a kick in the end we think the
magic might be real so there's no flash
photography allowed you have to believe
there's a jacket required policy we want
to believe in magic and we keep debating
it because some of us do and some of us
don't but also we were talking about
this this morning we want to believe in
Kyler Murray playing football okay like
we that's we want great story mitt so
whether it's true or not we want to
believe that because that's gonna spice
up the draft I want to believe you can
play both Dan
I mean Dionne and bow like that was I
cut my teeth on that as a sports yeah
why can't we have that anymore the money
and the injury because they weren't
quarterbacks yeah and I think when your
quarterback is not committed you know
he's got to be committed year-round and
and I think when you would see that and
then if he didn't play well then he'd
say well you know he's spending too much
time on base two four five for the
Royals last thing he should have been
Morgan I'm a watching tape or something
like that it's such a buzzkill because I
would love to see but if you had him
drafted by Oakland he's already drafted
by the A's mm-hm and you got the Raiders
with three first-round draft picks
couldn't you see a scenario where and
their triple-a team the aged triple-a
team is in Vegas so okay by the time he
gets the starting job they would be in
Vegas mm-hmm get to play baseball I'm
loving this
I mean I heard the poster with Bo with
the shoulder pads and the bat like
overhead that that was my ID on I love
Deion tune I wonder I wonder what role
Gruden would play in that because if
he's old school I don't know where you
come out that either comes out of that I
can't appreciate a guy who can do both
I remember guys did both or he's my full
commitment I don't want you playing for
the A's I want you here 24/7
it's a buzzkill yeah and I think that
that's a valid point when you
think of Gruden because he's the wild
card and you're not sure if he it still
feels like he's old school even though
you know modern times and I think that's
gonna decide if he's successful not is
is can he adapt to today it feels like
Gruden is still back 10 15 years ago it
does and from everything from the way he
talks to the way he dresses and
everything and it's like we're also the
other the number one topic now is like
we're sitting this this ridiculous crazy
almost farcical coaching spree that
we're going on it's I live I live up in
the suburbs up here all right and I have
a five-year-old son and I'm just now
entering this realm where as parents the
switchblades are coming out meaning they
want the best for their kids they want
the personal coach they want the private
instructor they want the specialist and
I feel like these young quarterbacks are
the kids like Jared Goff and Baker
Mayfield on all of them every on one of
these owners now says this is my private
my pride and joy my son I want to raise
him up to be an all-star I have to get
the special instructor no matter what I
have to pay no matter how to experience
the is because I have these instructors
I've talked to some of them out in the
party they're crackpots they don't know
what they're talking about they don't
know how to do a batting stance or
anything but they're pedigreed somehow
and they want to get paid that's what I
feel like going on these owners are
protecting their sons those quarterbacks
well it does feel like they've all come
up in this system where you have the 7
on 7s and then the elite 8 11 you know
camps and they go into the Manning camp
or Alabama's can't you know the fact
that you know Clemson's quarterback went
to Alabama's camp and then Lane Kiffin
told us on Monday I saw him as an 8th
grader yeah so they're seeing these kids
before they're even playing high school
Flores Arian said the same thing about
Jameis Winston's and I remember jabu
when he was 12 and so they're hiring
coaches who feel like they're 12 I like
it I think it's incredible and the
McVeigh thing is fascinating right now
because Sean McVeigh you weren't there
playing against America's team so I'm a
favorite I was America's coach he's
getting everybody hired he's getting
everybody jobs it's crazy like remember
we I moved here a couple summers ago and
I moved here in the prime of when that
pokemons go thing was going around and
these imbeciles are running through
Central Park chasing after cartoons I
feel like right now it's like a coach
Eamon like
everyone's just running after trying to
catch them all get the little coaches we
got the Lafleur thing and it animates
and everything everyone's trying to get
the McVeigh but what's interesting is if
McVeigh loses this weekend though I
knows it's like alright so you can get
me a job and you're cool and you got a
beard and sexy and but can you even win
we're all trying to copy in McVeigh no
one wants to copy anthony and lynn
shooting everyone want a copy belcheck
and peterson mcveigh's great but you
will lose this weekend that bloom is off
the rose he hasn't won a playoff game
yeah eebee own two both at home and you
know two years ago Adam GaSe was the hot
property I remember it you gotta get
Adam GaSe I love gasps I love gates
because he doesn't care that I love him
he doesn't care what you think i watch
these reality shows you I watch The
Amazing Race or survive there's always
one character winds up winning and it's
the same soundbite every single year a
bachelor bath right they always say I
didn't come here to make friends that
person always wins that's the strategy
the other people have friends for life
limbo gates did not come here to make
friends not with the media and not with
the quarterback he does it his way and I
really like that because I don't want to
be like now I don't know if he's any
good you can be a great coordinator my
problem is when you become a great
coordinator we all of a sudden say well
EB you got to make him a head coach
there are certain guys who are meant to
be pitching coaches and not manager for
the percent certain guys who regret all
of béla checks offensive and defensive
coordinators should have stayed
offensive and defensive course otherwise
Romeo Crennel all those guys even Matt
Patricia maybe Bill O'Brien I don't know
yeah I don't think Bill O'Brien - head
coach neither do the Colts they just
destroy them they just destroy them
Texan some guys would just play within
yourself you know respectfully somebody
like Dirk cutter who just got let go and
that was it's not a head coach but a
great coordinator yeah I love it as a
coordinator not a head coach you bring
up a good point though that is is gase
one of those guys who who can't hit the
turnaround 25 foot jumper but if you
give him a perfect pass will do the
layup I don't know I think I think gay
still has it in him I like it that's
when he took the Dolphins to the
playoffs with Ryan Tannehill his first
year second year he gets hurt he's with
Cutler that was nonsense year this year
a tad a hell banged up again that 2016
year was pretty awesome but we're
bringing in these guys because they're
quarterback whispers that's it kitchens
gets hired because Baker Mayfield you
proved to be great when he got out from
under huge accent you're bringing in
Kliff Kingsbury because the Josh Rosen
now you're gonna bring an Adam GaSe
because his Sam door know everybody's
committing their team to one player
mm-hmm
that's not that's not the right approach
to have you're bringing in a floor
because he's an offensive guy and he's
gonna help aaron rodgers somehow now
denver didn't do that with Vic Fangio
they went the other way yeah bent and
and their quarterbacks need more help
than any other team I don't even know if
they have a quarterback he'll make don't
it's a cool thing because you see the
games last weekend I think the highest
point totals 24 points yeah teams in the
teens there was a team that didn't get
to ten and I think this weekend is me
the same thing everyone says the Saints
are gonna put up 50 and the Colts and
Chiefs can go back and forth I don't
think so and if you look at these teams
we built around one player look at the
cults I know the Colts are not sexy and
it's Indiana and they're not fun and on
and on and on and we talk about them in
our shows like more Cowboys what Cowboys
I love the Colts because they built it
from inside out and their guards are
good and their tackles are good and I
know they're doesn't sell jerseys no fat
heads and stuff but damn they will run
you right over I love that and I think
they're gonna win this weekend but do
you guys and I know that there's it's
formulaic yeah if you watch you know the
show with Skip Bayless or watch first
take they will hit the Cowboys as often
as possible when they're not in LeBron
so the bran yeah and the cowboy as much
as possible you being a football show
are you told something let's work in the
cowboy someway somehow every single day
absolutely not no no and remember we
started our first season was 2016 which
was a glorious season for the Cowboys
that's dak and Zeke rookie jumping into
the kettle everything no not at all in
fact I think we take pride in hitting
every single team like I don't know
maybe it's maybe it's to our fault maybe
we should start more with the Cowboys
those shows that you mentioned they're
successful yeah and I know a lot of Cup
but also it's like I also think that
those shows annoy a lot of people it
because this is too much cowboys and
LeBron and it's it's this debate as an
entertainer someone on TV do you want to
have the highest-rated show possible
which there are ways or do you want to
have what you feel is the best show
possible
I think we could probably have better
ratings on our show if we talk more
Cowboys but I don't want to do that I
like to do
we do I can't do it and I don't know
that I just I I think this this show
evolves naturally we come in and we go
what what do we want to talk about today
not hey let's talk about dak Prescott is
he a better quarterback than Jerrod golf
mmm like let's let's shoehorn something
in here let's talk about Jerry Jones is
250 million dollars you do it yeah and
let's tie it to a social issue in some
way just get some juice I guess but I
even let's talk about LeBron good or bad
I just I that's not how I was brought up
to do this you do the story that's in
front of you you do the right story at
the right time and looked at we
sacrifice ratings I'm sure if we talked
about the Cowboys and LeBron we would do
better
mm-hmm I can't do that every day I know
and I do applaud the fact that Skip
Bayless can somehow it's a town news
show every day where you touch on those
two topics and Stephen a Smith they're
able to do that like I just can't do
that
I can't either and it's not just the
topic then you get to the next layer of
what is the take
you know I my burn is I wish I always
want to say something original and what
happens is if you want to say something
original and stick out you find yourself
getting very extreme either extremely
positive this is the best player in the
history of the world or you just destroy
people it can be dangerous very
dangerous because you don't even mean it
but you're just so motivated by saying
something different and I want to give
you a compliment I think you're one of
the few people who can just talk sports
without saying something completely
ostentatious that you don't even mean
but damn it got six thousand retweets
I'll say it again tomorrow I it's a it's
an art right now and we try to do it
hard but you could fall into the hot
take trap because you want to have a
cool opinion and you believe it I think
you can maybe justify it but then you
see when you start to see those retweets
and all that you start to believe a lot
of things that's a whole religion
they're on Twitter
it really is can't do it I got it okay
here here's a hunt take what you got oh
I love this give it to me if Jason
Garrett's coaching for his job this
weekend and I'm saying yes or no yeah
now Jason Garrett extended his job last
weekend that's a big win that's a big
win for dak yeah
it's not a heartache if you understand
what we're doing Kyle I think I think
you undersold it
I think nevermind Garrett I think
belcheck Scotia first job now you cannot
lose at home to a team or 7a no against
I think listen all right okay so Daniels
waiting in the wing break shaman at the
bit Brady playing from his job
listen Bryan where throws a nice ball
people sleep on Bryan you're expecting
Brady you sorry I would think so yeah I
think my Holmes is playing for his job
too
have you ever seen Chad Henne other
thing whistles when it comes out of his
hand
okay sleep on honey now we got we got
something everyone was just about to
change that whoa this is what you guys
need to do yeah on good morning football
you just have fake context we'll pass it
back and just call it fake context and
somebody dresses up as skip bayless like
Kay Adams dress up is Skip Bayless and
we'll call it were steak or maybe hot
potato and we'll just pass it back and
forth yeah but you just make up a hottie
right just like they do my take on Kyler
Murray I think you try basketball okay
you know I mean there's there's more
money longer life expectancy golf you
can play till you're 80 and that
baseball or football and everybody's
done that okay so I got how it takes
this is simple thanks for stopping by
this is thrilled to be here I have a lot
of memories of listening to you and
watching you I'm really really
appreciate a bit to be here thank you
cos it's cool now Kyle Brant NFL Network
good morning football quad host not it's
not co-host
quanto Costa for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]